[Musik]
in der halbzeitpause guten abend zu
einer früheren und kompakten 19 uhr
ausgabe japan ist geschockt ex-premier
shinzo abe kam heute bei einem attentat
ums leben aber unterstützte einen
parteikollegen der rechts konservativen
ldp mit einer wahlkampfrede als
plötzlich ein mann das feuer auf ihn
eröffneten der 67 jährige der den
inselstaat länger als jeder andere
politiker vor ihm regierte erlag seinen
verletzungen im krankenhaus
ulf röller berichtet
es wirkt wie ein ganz normaler
wahlkampfauftritt von jean zu aber im
hintergrund kann man schon auf handy
bildern den attentäter erkennen um 11.30
dann zwei schüsse sind zu hören
der attentäter ein 41 jähriger
ehemaliger marinesoldat wird sofort
überwältigt mit einer selbstgebauten
waffe hat er aber von hinten in den hals
geschossen sein tatmotiv ist bisher
unklar
fassungslos japans regierungschef key
mit tränenerstickter stimme erklärte
der angriff während der wahl sei ein
inakzeptabler angriff auf das fundament
der demokratie
er verurteile ihn aufs schärfste
aber war der regierungschef mit der
längsten amtszeit der konservative stand
für einen harten kurs gegen china und
für die aufrüstung des landes das
attentat trifft eine nation die mit die
strengsten waffengesetze der welt hat
und in dem nur sehr wenige menschen
opfer von schusswaffen werden
wir sind doch nicht die usa ich bin so
schockiert aber doch nur eine rede
halten sollen
am tatort suchen sie nun nach weiteren
spuren japan ist geschockt und fragt
sich warum
weiter mit einem eklat beim
außenministertreffen der g-20 auf bali
mit dabei russlands top-diplomat lavrov
der dem westen erst schwere vorwürfe
machte und dann einfach verschwand ohne
sich die antwort anzuhören die kam von
außenministerin berbalk über weiterhin
tiefe gräben und das denkwürdige treffen
informiert andreas künast
das ist nur schwer erträglich ist den
russischen außenminister wieder auf dem
roten teppich wieder auf der bühne der
welt zu sehen müssen in der
indonesischen gastgeberin die europäer
sagen der amerikaner und die kanadierin
die sich in blau gelb darauf gegenüber
setzen will aber lavrov wird nicht lange
bleiben in einem raum mit den vertretern
des westens mit den vertretern der
ukraine die er mal wieder beschuldigt
erst den krieg dann die hungerkrise
provoziert zu haben als außenministerin
berbalk im namen der g7 widersprechen
will die überraschung la france ist
recht habe dabei der wichtigen frage wie
wir diese weltweite ernährungskrise in
den griff bekommen war der russische
außenminister nicht anwesend dabei hat
la france auch freunde auf bali der
chinesische außenminister wang je den
die sanktionen des westens ab sendet
heute aber auch kooperation signale ganz
anders am 13
von unseren westlichen kollegen kommen
keine antworten nur tollwütige große
phobie
es geht im moment nichts mehr zwischen
russland und dem westen das sergey
lavrov nicht bereit war den drei minuten
zuzuhören die deutsche außenministerin
vorbereitet hatte zeigt dass der weg zu
ernsthaften verhandlungen nach diesen
g20-treffen weiter ist als davor dass
wir nah vor fragen
wann beenden sie den krieg kommt nicht
gut an die indonesischen
sicherheitsleute schmeißen uns raus
deutschlands größter gasimporteur
juniper hat offiziell staatshilfe beim
bund beantragt bundeskanzler scholz hat
inzwischen hilfe zugesagt weil weniger
gas aus russland kommt muss der konzern
gas am weltmarkt teuer zukaufen um seine
kunden weiter zu versorgen die höheren
kosten durfte der importeur bislang aber
nicht weitergeben und macht deshalb hohe
verluste
bundestag und bundesrat haben grünes
licht für den nato-beitritt schwedens
und finnlands gegeben alle 30
bündnisstaaten müssen zustimmen auch die
türkei die gilt nach wie vor als
unsicherheitsfaktor
rund ein jahr ist es her dass die
bundeswehr und ihre verbündeten
überstürzt nach 20 jahren aus
afghanistan abgezogen chaotische szenen
damals am flughafen in kabul während
einer internationalen
evakuierungsaktion versuchten
verzweifelte afghanen an bord der
rettende flugzeuge zu gelangen ein
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag soll
jetzt klären ob die damalige große
koalition die brisanz der lage im land
zu spät erkannte ines trams
nur magazine im camp der deutschen
soldaten mit wehmut und wut schaute auf
diese fotos zwölf jahre hat er als
wachmann für die bundeswehr in
afghanistan gearbeitet mit vier seiner
kinder ist er heute in lübeck in
sicherheit doch seine volljährigen söhne
dürfen im rahmen des orts kraft
verfahrens bislang nicht nach
deutschland
wir haben als ortskräfte verantwortung
übernommen und die deutschen
sicherheitskräfte unterstützt und
beschützt jetzt ist die bundesregierung
daran verantwortung für uns übernehmen
wir schon august letztes jahr überhastet
verlassen die westlichen nationen das
land als die taliban die macht
übernehmen viele afghanen wollen mit
werden zurückgelassen auch viele
ortskräfte rund 21.000 schafften es
bislang nach deutschland doch rund
10.000 warten bis heute erste sitzung
des untersuchungsausschusses
er soll klären wie die lage so falsch
eingeschätzt werden konnte warum so
zögerlich evakuiert wurden gerade die
umstände des ja sehr überstürzten endes
dieser mission nach 20 jahren
zwingen uns dazu ursachenforschung zu
betreiben wollen hat das eigentlich
gelegen es geht am ende ja auch darum
empfehlungen auszusprechen um zu
verhindern dass sich ein solches chaos
und ein ein solcher überstürzter abzug
mit den vielen humanitären folgen die
bis heute nachwirken eben nicht
wiederholt familie ja sie hofft dass mit
dem u ausschuss die zurückgebliebenen
ortskräfte und ihre angehörigen mit
ihren nöten wieder mehr aufmerksamkeit
bekommen
freispruch für michelle platini und
joseph blatter im prozess in der schweiz
gegen die beiden ehemaligen fußball
spitzenfunktionäre ging es um betrug und
untreue
2011 hatte der damalige fifa präsident
blatter dem früheren uefa chef platini 2
millionen franken aus den kassen des
weltverbandes ausbezahlt lohn für
beratertätigkeiten so ihre aussage
das sei nicht zu widerlegen urteilte
jetzt das gericht
ja beim wetter wenig änderungen mehr
dazu gleich von özden terli das heute
journal gibt es um 10 vor 10 mit
marietta slomka um jetzt viel spaß bei
der zweiten halbzeit vielen dank und bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter wetter bestimmt ist immer noch
dieses riesige azorenhoch und auf seiner
ostseite kommt immer noch kühle luft und
etwas regen ist mit einer leichten
luftmassengrenze morgen tagesverlauf
möglich war es dann nach südosten
wanders in der nacht gibt es etwas regen
ganz im norden und richtung osten
richtung erzgebirge sonst aber trockenes
wetter bei tiefsten temperaturen von
sieben grad an den alpen und 15 grad
richtung nordsee und dort kräftiger wind
aus nordwestlichen richtungen teils
stürmisch sonst ziehen die schauer mit
dieser kleinen luftmassengrenze weiter
nach südosten und das bei höchsten
temperaturen von 28 grad im südwesten
und 18 grad richtung nordsee die
nächsten tage am sonntag einzelne
schauer und dann wird es allmählich
immer trockener montag und dienstag dann
sogar bis 30 grad ein schöner abend